good afternoon everyone our help network
needs an overall
and the overall must be built around
people who work in the health
network
we are understaffed in our hospitals
bursaries have been set up for nursing
students
but it takes three to five years to
train a nurse
and i take this opportunity to launch
and appeal to all young and old who are
looking for a new career
with the aging of the population
we'll need more and more people to
provide care to our fellow citizens
so for anyone who cares about the fate
of others it's such a rewarding
profession
so we're doing
all what needs to be done to have a
stronger healthcare network in the
future but it will take some time before
we rebuild
our health network it will take some
time to increase the capacity of our
hospitals and in the meantime we must
remain cautious
starting next monday january
31 private gatherings will be allowed up
to four people or two family bubbles
restaurants will be open to open their
dining rooms at fifty percent capacity
four people maximum are two family
bubbles per table with the vaccination
passport
i'm very sensitive also to the
importance of sport among young people
so on january 31 young people
in primary and secondary schools will be
able to resume
extracurricular activities
sports are also open to civilians for
those under 18. it will be allowed for a
maximum of 25 people at the time but no
competition for the moment
we will then have a second phase
on february the 7th
we will allow allow
performance halls and cinemas to open at
50 capacity with a maximum of 500 people
also
from february 7
places of workshop will be able to
reopen at 50 capacity with a maximum of
250 people always with the vaccination
passport
in the meantime
if you want to help to help
the healthcare staff
the best thing you can do is to get your
first second and third dose
this greatly reduces your chances of
ending up
in the hospital this is important
especially for people
age 60 and over
we have room you can even bring your
appointments forward so be careful
thank you